so we have three different shapes we
have stars we have squares and we have
triangles and we have a different number
of each shape so we have five stars we
have three squares and we have six
triangles you don't see them all here
this is just telling us how many of each
of these shapes we have so if we have
five stars three squares and six
triangles how many total shapes do we
have well you're probably saying maybe I
should add these numbers because I'm
trying to find the total number of
shapes and if you said that I would say
you are right
so let's add those numbers so we want to
add we want to add five plus three plus
three plus six plus six so what is this
going to be
well what's five plus three five
triangles plus three squares
well five plus three is eight so this is
going to be eight and then we still have
to add six so we're still going to add
six
now what's eight plus six well you may
or may not know this and if you don't
know this it's well you could count
things out if you like but it is a good
thing to know just off of the top of
your head so if you don't know it yet
put this in your brain 8 plus 6 is 14 8
plus 6 is equal to 14 so 5 plus 3 plus 6
is also equal to 14 now one question you
might have is well does it matter the
order that I do this in well let's try
it the other way around
let's write it again let's write 5 plus
3 plus 3 plus 6 plus 6 instead of adding
the 5 in the 3 first let's have the 3
and the 6 first so what is 3 plus 6 well
that's going to be 9 and we're going to
have 5 plus 9 5 plus 9 well once again
if you know that you'll know it's 14 if
you don't know that that's another good
thing to put in your brain and just to
know 5 plus 9
is equal to 14 if you don't know that
and you don't believe me take some
pebbles out and have five pebbles and
then nine more and then you'll you'll
see that when you add them together you
get to 14 but this is just a good thing
for you to know in your brain and you
can dump the other way around you could
have added five and six first and you
get on eleven plus three would have also
been 14 either way you have 14 total
shapes